le salon de l'agriculture porte de
versailles c'est chaque année un
événement mais qu'en pense-t-on au fin
fond des campagnes
nous sommes aujourd'hui à
neuvy-saint-sépulchre dans l'indre on va
donner la parole à des habitants mais
également à des gens de passage
bonjour marque aussi une tablette et une
première question pour vous vous
écoutons que représente pour vous le
salon de l'agriculture
pour moi le salon de l'agriculture
représente un événement national
[Musique]
on
ça représente
le travail de pour moi de toute la
france de tous les agriculteurs de
france que soit grand qu'il soit petit
ça permet que les gens de vie de la
ville connaisse enfin ce que sont les
vrais animaux sur pied parce que dans le
dans l'assiette ils savent peut-être pas
trop d'où ils sortent mais ça ne
représente pas la globalité de ce que
l'agriculteur dans l'erdre
aujourd'hui le monde rigole souffre et
on ne montre pas là bas ce qu elle cette
misère on représente vraiment le plus
beau côté de l'agriculture depuis
combien de temps existe il selon vous 50
50 je dirais je dirais je dirais ça va
me revenir
depuis quand existe au moins depuis 55
ans 50 ans car mon père qui était
agriculteur éleveur
les quais dans les monts du lyonnais
allaient quand ils étaient jeunes se
rendait au sa demande systématiquement
aux éleveurs de l'indre os qui compense
et vous c'est peut-être un petit peu
limite mais à l'échelle du département
français je pense que c'est peut-être
raisonnable je pense que c'est pas assez
après si les onze éleveurs représente la
diversité une grande diversité
pourquoi pas mais je pense que c'est pas
elle sait c'est déjà ça fait connaître
les éleveurs de du département de l'ain
est - ce qui valorise aussi notre
département est ce important de mettre
en avant le monde de l'élevage en 2019
plus que jamais on s'est élevé je pense
en france on a une bonne filière
c'est important aussi de devoir là la
qualité des bêtes la traçabilité de la
viande
on a vu avec les problèmes de la pologne
que ça fait donc pour moi c'est
important et les images on sait très
bien que nos éleveurs français ont des
ça va faire sympathique je dirais et que
d'autres pays se laissent un peu plus a
dit quoi donc il faut c'est vrai une
réglementation mais vive la france quand
même plus je suis désolé on sait faire
je pense qu'il faut revenir aux valeurs
simples en valeur pure
et revenir au commerce de proximité donc
système favoriser tout
toutoune aux paysans tout aux
agriculteurs du coin
[Musique]
on
là haut